[Music]  sonic the hedgehog you're no match for  me  i will destroy this planet  so nice when diabolical evil lives up to  the height  sonic this is your moment  you're unskilled  untrained  unworthy  you forgot unstoppable i think i just  threw up in my mouth  the hedgehog 2 coming soon  i have been called many names vengeance  the spiky supernova but you may call me  sorry blue  justice  here we go  hello  hedgehog  you're never going to get my power oh  contrera fair  meet knuckle  i was expecting more of a fight  so nice when diabolical evil lives up to  the height  that wasn't too bad  seriously pretending to be batman blue  justice trademark pending  sonic the hedgehog  you're no match for me  this is your moment to be the big hero  oh great the winter soldier  it is my destiny to destroy you  work smarter not harder  that wasn't too bad  sonic the hedgehog 2.  [Music]  you